problema número 51 a continuación se
muestra un diagrama que viene de una
demostración del teorema de pitágoras y
aquí ponen el diagrama ok que he
enunciado no se va a usar en la
demostración del teorema de pitágoras ok
me imagino que lo que quieren que
hagamos es dar la demostración clásica
en la cual encontramos el área de este
cuadrado grande de dos formas distintas
entonces vamos a hacer esa y luego vemos
si eso concuerda con las opciones que
nos dan bueno la demostración dice así
aquí tenemos cuatro triángulos
rectángulos congruentes 1 2 3 y 4 sale
como son triángulos rectángulos
congruentes entonces este lado me debe
hasta aquí este mide a ésto me debe este
mide a etcétera vale bueno y además este
ángulo este ángulo es el complemento de
este de acá digamos si éste es xy éste y
los dos son complementarios suman 90
grados este de acá es x x con 10 90
grados y por lo tanto este que marcan de
90 de adeveras es de 90 entonces la
figura central de adeveras es un
cuadrado vale cuatro ángulos iguales y
cuatro lados iguales muy bien entonces
la idea ahora es calcular el área del
cuadrado grandote una forma de hacerlo
es elevar su lado al cuadrado es decir
tomar a b y elevarlo al cuadrado esto es
un binomio al cuadrado así que nos queda
a cuadrada más dos veces saben más b
cuadrada esa es una forma otra forma es
sumar el área de estos cuatro triángulos
rectángulos y luego el área de este
cuadrado de aquí bueno estos triángulos
rectángulos tienen todos base y altura b
entonces el área de cada uno de ellos de
cada triángulo lo voy a poner así es
igual a un medio de a por b la mitad de
la base por la altura entonces el área
de los cuatro de los cuatro triángulos
es dos veces a por b es cuatro veces
esto de aquí arriba que es dos veces a
por b
entonces el área del cuadrado grandote
es igual a esta expresión que al mismo
tiempo es igual al área de los cuatro
triángulos chiquitos de estos cuatro
triángulos chiquitos más el área del
cuadrado central este cuadrado de acá
vale
y bueno cuánto tiene este cuadrado de
área pues como es un cuadrado es su lado
al cuadrado esta hipotenusa me desde
entonces el lado del cuadrado s de esta
forma que hay que sumarse al cuadrado
entonces tenemos esta igualdad de aquí
vale está ya la probamos encontrando el
área de dos formas distintas y ahora en
esta igualdad podemos restar dos sabes
de ambos lados y concluimos que a
cuadrado más b cuadrada es igual a c
cuadra muy bien esa es la demostración
del teorema de pitágoras vamos a ver qué
opciones nos dan para los enunciados que
no se utilizan a ver
a el área de un triángulo es igual a un
medio de la base por la altura estoy
aquí si lo utilizamos ve los cuatro
triángulos son congruentes
esto también lo utilizamos verdad para
justificar que este ángulo de adeveras
fuera de 90 y para simplemente
multiplicar el área de uno de los
triángulos por cuatro va a ser el área
de el cuadrado interior es igual a la
mitad del área del cuadrado grande no
esto suena que no lo utilizamos entonces
me imagino que la respuesta es c pero
vamos a ver la de a ver qué dicen de el
área del cuadrado grande es igual a la
suma de las áreas del cuadrado pequeño y
los cuatro triángulos congruentes claro
que usamos esto esto fue la parte
fundamental de nuestra prueba entonces
ab y de si las utilizamos y se no de
hecho dudo que se sea cierta en general
porque este cuadrado puede ser muy
grandote si los triángulos tienen mucha
diferencia entre la base y la altura
pero bueno vaya a la respuesta es si se
no se utiliza en la demostración muy
bien vamos al problema 52
dice la hipotenusa de un triángulo
rectángulo mide 5 y un cateto mide 2
cuánto mide el otro cateto o sea
básicamente nos están preguntando si no
sabemos el teorema de pitágoras entonces
voy a dibujar aquí el triángulo nos
dicen que la hipotenusa mide 55 y que un
cateto mide 2 y nos preguntan nos
preguntan por la medida del otro cateto
bueno aplicando el teorema de pitágoras
aquí tenemos que x al cuadrado más 2 al
cuadrado es igual a 5 al cuadrado
entonces x al cuadrado más 4 es igual a
25 restando 4 de ambos lados x al
cuadrado es igual a 21 y sacando raíz x
es igual a raíz de 21 o menos raíz de 21
pero como x es el lado de un triángulo
debe ser positivo entonces x es igual a
raíz de 21 opción b muy bien vamos al
problema 53
a este tiene un dibujo padre dice una
nueva tubería se está construyendo para
redirigir el flujo de petróleo alrededor
de una reserva natural aquí está el
dibujo me imagino que este triángulo de
adentro es la reserva natural le voy a
poner por ahí un lago un lago muy bien
entonces a continuación se muestra el
mapa con la tubería vieja y nueva ok
aproximadamente cuántas millas extra
extra recorrerá el petróleo con la nueva
ruta muy bien entonces tenemos que
encontrar pues cuántas millas recorre
ahora las millas que recorre ahora son
60 más 32 o sea 92 o sea con la nueva
ruta
nueva ruta recorremos 92 92 millas bajas
60 32 y queremos ver qué tanto es eso
comparado con la tubería vieja pero la
tubería vieja no nos la dan vamos a
ponerle x y entonces una vez más tenemos
un triángulo rectángulo hay que hacer el
teorema de pitágoras hay que utilizarlo
vale entonces nos quedaría x al cuadrado
es igual a 32 al cuadrado más 60 al
cuadrado 32 al cuadrado chin es un
número muy grande aquí podré factorizar
algo no sé si factor hizo un 4 me queda
8 y 15
creo que creo que eso no mejora mucho
las cosas mejor voy a hacer las cuentas
entonces 32 al cuadrado 32 al cuadrado
haber 32 por 30 y 22 por 32 de 64 3 por
32 396
entonces nos queda 42 llegamos 10 10
1024 entonces x al cuadrado es igual a
1024 más 60 al cuadrado 6 x 6 es 36 y
hay que poner dos ceros más 3600 muy
bien entonces x al cuadrado es igual a
1024 3600 o sea es igual a 4 mil 624
vale ahora cuál será la raíz de 4.624
para encontrar el valor de x
no sé a lo mejor las opciones nos dan
alguna pista a ver 24 al cuadrado pues
es menos que 30 al cuadrado y 30 al
cuadrado es 900 entonces éste no alcanza
éste no alcanza 68 está muy cerquita de
70 70 al cuadrado es cuatro mil
novecientos éste se ve prometedor y
además ocho por ocho es 64 entonces éste
al cuadrado termina en cuatro a ver
vamos a probarlo
68 x 68 8 x 8 64 llevamos 6 6 x 8 48 y 6
que llevamos 54 si 8 x 8 64 llevamos 66
846 por 8 48 llevamos 4 6 por 6 36 y 4
que llevamos 40 44 y 8 12 llevamos 11 y
56 a mira si justo es 68 vale entonces x
x es igual a 68 y ahora lo que tenemos
que hacer es encontrar aquí pasó algo
interesante o sea yo no sé para qué
utilice estas opciones si estas opciones
son para la diferencia queremos las
millas extra pero casualmente en las
opciones me encontré me encontré el
valor de la longitud de la tubería vieja
a lo mejor es de esos trucos que
utilizan para para hacernos tener la
pregunta mal por no leerla bien pero
creo que le salió al revés a los que
hicieron el examen más bien nos ayudaron
a encontrar el valor de la tubería vieja
pero pero bueno vamos a hacer lo que nos
piden entonces lo que nos piden son las
millas extra entonces tenemos que ver
cuánto es de 68 a 92
92 68 92 68 es igual a 24 aja entonces
son 24 millas extra opción a va eso
estuvo un poco truculento bueno quizás
no truculento pero pero interesante
bueno problema 54 wendy está usando
regla y compás para hacer la
construcción mostrada ok que descripción
encaja mejor con lo que wendy está
tratando de hacer y nos dan algunas
opciones bueno pues vamos a ver vamos a
ver qué está haciendo buen día al
parecer el punto p es dado y en la recta
él es dada esta recta de acá vamos a
ponerle n se puede construir con regla
haciendo que pase por p y podemos
construir este punto vaya como la
intersección luego al parecer éste con
la punta metálica aquí
wendy trazo este arco
y observo donde cortaba aquí y aquí y
luego y luego pues como que marcó este
arco de acá que es la longitud entre
estos dos puntos entonces para ir
marcando cosas este mide lo mismo que
éste porque son este son radios de un
círculo el círculo que dibuje el compás
y este de acáp quién sabe cuánto mide
pero tiene cierta meditaba bueno y luego
al parecer este arco lo copió aquí
arriba entonces éste también mide dos
rayitas aquí encontró un punto que
parece ser un punto interesante donde
éste mide lo mismo que esté otra vez son
radios del círculo que se trazó y
finalmente hizo este trazo verdad este
de acá y es que al parecer resultó de
copiar el de acá o sea copiar esta
longitud de medida 3 de medida 3 rayitas
entonces pues bueno y logró construir
este triángulo congruente a éste pero
aquí no hay nada de congruencias pero
observa como estos dos triángulos son
congruentes este ángulo no se de medida
alfa es lo mismo que este ángulo de
medida alfa vaya miden lo mismo y
entonces está recta
estos dos puntos p y el que acabamos de
construir si no me está quedando derecho
a ver si ahí sale ahí está esta recta
resulta paralela a él entonces esta es
una construcción para trazar una recta
digamos n paralela a él que pase por p
vamos a ver si eso está en las opciones
una recta x p paralela a la recta l
sí sí eso es exactamente lo que hicimos
entonces la respuesta es ah y las otras
dicen p qué interfecta a l nos están la
interfecta congruente perpendicular no
pues se me hace que es eso una recta por
p paralela a l muy bien problema 55 dado
el ángulo
cuál es el primer paso para construir su
bisectriz bueno aquí nos ponen un
diagrama lo que yo haría para construir
la bisectriz a ver si me acuerdo de cómo
es es empezar en a y tomar cualquier
apertura con el compás podría hacer esa
pero al parecer aquí se la tomaron hasta
bs
vale entonces con eso podemos construir
b y c eso es lo primero que hacemos
luego con esa misma apertura
y tomamos de a quien ve la
circunferencia de la circunferencia con
ese radio más o menos algo así más o
menos bueno quizás no es el mismo radio
porque ya no tu cuenta y luego en ce
también de forma que se traza en estos
dos arcos que estaban indicados en el
diagrama original y de ahí nos va a dar
un punto y se puede ver que ese punto
está sobre sobre la bisectriz pero bueno
no nos vamos a meter mucho en eso son
muchos detalles básicamente va a salir
de qué ave de abed y hace de son
triángulos congruentes pero bueno te
dejo para que lo pienses tantito esa es
la idea de hacer la construcción vamos a
ver cuáles nos proponen como el primer
paso para ver para ver qué elegimos
a dibujar el rayo ave no pues primero
hay que construir de osea a de si dibuja
la la bisectriz pero pues primero hay
que hay que construir de y antes de eso
hay que construir b&c entonces no la
opción a no no es de dibujar un segmento
que conecte p y c que conecte viste no
pues eso no sirve de nada no a lo mejor
el arco conecta abc pero el segmento
pues no lo utilizamos para nada entonces
ésta tampoco es sé de los puntos b y c
dibujar arcos iguales que se intersectan
en d pues eso fue lo que hicimos pero en
el segundo paso entonces ya estamos
acercándonos al primer paso pero todavía
no es de del punto dibujar un arco que
intersecte los lados del ángulo en
puntos b y c sí eso es justo lo primero
que hicimos verdad tomamos el compás
aquí acuérdate un compás es más o menos
un compás es más o menos algo así es un
instrumento que tiene una punta metálica
y tiene un lado así y luego hay otro
lado donde puedes poner el lápiz algo de
este estilo buena gran chiste del compás
también tiene aquí como una no sé como
un soporte para darle vueltas pero el
chiste del compás es que permite tratar
el otro lado el del lápiz permite trazar
este círculos vale entonces sí o sea
justo lo primero que hicimos fue
utilizar el compás ponerlo con la punta
metálica aquí trazar un círculo y
fijarnos donde cortaba para construir
puntos beige y vale bueno entonces la
respuesta es de de es el primer paso que
se hace para construir la bisectriz de
un ángulo creo que ya me pasé muchísimo
el tiempo le voy a dejar aquí nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo para continuar con
el 56